SPEAKER: Hidden in the
natural world around us
are powerful biological tools
whose potential scientists are
just beginning to unlock.
For billions of years,
bacteria have been under attack
from viruses.
But bacteria developed
clever defense mechanisms
to remember these
viruses and fight back.
Recently, scientists harnessed
one of these natural tools
called CRISPR Cas9 and created
a powerful gene editing
technology with the potential
to treat human disease.
But Cas9 isn't the
only CRISPR tool
with applications
for human health.
A team of scientists found that
a cousin of Cas9, called Cas13,
can be harnessed to actually
detect human disease.
Here's how Cas13 works in
its natural environment.
First it hunts for viral
RNA using an RNA guide.
When it finds its viral target,
Cas13 becomes activated.
In some circumstances,
it cuts any RNA
it encounters-- a process
termed collateral cleavage.
It is this mechanism that
scientists at the McGovern
Institute.
Broad Institute, and
Harvard University
harnessed to create Sherlock,
a highly sensitive tool
to detect infectious
diseases in humans.
Here's how the Sherlock
detection system works.
First, researchers take
a sample from a patient
with a possible viral
infection, like the flu.
Then they amplify the
levels of RNA in it
and add reporters that
are sensitive to Cas13.
Then an engineered CRISPR
Cas13 is added to the sample.
This Cas13 is
programmed with a guide
RNA that is designed to find
only virus RNA and bind to it.
When this happens, Cas13
activates its cleaving
mechanism and begins
randomly slicing nearby RNA,
including the reporters.
Since each end of the reporter
carries a different label,
Cas13 separates
these two signatures,
creating a unique signal
within the sample.
The sample is then applied to
a commercial flow detection
system.
If the sample is
negative for flu,
the reporter remains intact and
collects at the first detection
line.
If the sample is
positive for flu,
it collects at a
different location,
making a diagnosis easy to spot.
So easy, in fact, Sherlock
can be used in the field
to detect emerging infectious
diseases and outbreaks,
like Ebola virus.
Before Sherlock,
field samples had
to be refrigerated and shipped
to labs with expensive gene
sequencing equipment.
Now Sherlock can be adapted to
detect any genetic signature,
even ones associated with cancer
in virtually any location.
CRISPR Cas9 and Cas13
are just two examples
of natural biological
systems that scientists
have modified to fight genetic
and infectious disease.
The question remains--
what other tools
are out there in the
natural world just
waiting to be discovered?
[MUSIC PLAYING]